hello everyone and welcome to face off i
am your host
cabot phillips we're joined today for a
good old-fashioned battle of wits
between two distinguished
distinguished guests first we have daily
wire host and best-selling author
according to everyone except the new
york times mr michael knowles
michael thanks for joining us thank you
for having me on my own show it is so
nice to have you i'm really glad that
you could make it to your show and next
is best-selling author and host of the
reuben report mr dave ruben dave thanks
for stepping into the arena
new york times best-selling author
begrudgingly
by the new york times we refuse to
acknowledge that list uh but we will get
into it now you guys will have plenty of
opportunities to disagree in the next
couple minutes because we're going to
get into base off
gentlemen you've both been serving
honorably on the front lines of a war
the culture war and because of that
courageous service you're both heroes in
the hearts and minds of americans
everywhere
but it's time for us to see how much you
know about this culture war that you
have been fighting this culture that you
are trying to protect this is face off
culture war edition
the rules are simple i will ask a
question you will have 15 seconds to
give an answer on your whiteboards
you're going to write out the answer the
winner of this competition will be the
ultimate culture warrior the loser will
have to read a 30-second commercial on
their own show about why their audience
needs to listen to the other guy's show
does that work for both of you do you
both agree here in the sovereign place
absolutely
i do agree i just want to say as the
elder of this game that if this was 1985
culture war i'd probably do a lot better
it does strike me that if we're culture
warriors
the whole meaning of that is that we
hate the pop culture and are reactionary
and don't know anything about it so this
will be a true test of ignorance
that's what we're going to call this
that'll be subtitled a test of ignorance
and ineptitude from michael and dave all
right michael i'm going to toss to you
because it's time to face off but first
i think you have an important word for
us i do i do this video is brought to
you by exodus 90. when you want to tune
out all the nonsense in our culture and
really focus in on what matters exodus
90 we'll have more from them later but
first let us test our cultural knowledge
first off i'm jumping right into it
this foreign netflix series dominated
viewing hours in 2021 more than doubling
the next closest series with 1.6 billion
viewing hours
what was this 2021 netflix show
the number one show
are we ready they are ready to give
their answers gentlemen what do we got
the crown
and squid game the correct answer is
squid game
yes what went to mr rubin
i watched it last night episode four man
a lot of blood that beat the crown you
know i watched squid i actually enjoyed
squid game it's kind of i mean all all
the show is is just watching koreans get
slaughtered so it's a little dark but i
did enjoy the show i can't believe that
beat the crown
by a lot wow oh my gosh
england
we're over that it's all about korean
koreans yeah okay all right are you not
a big k-pop fan either michael i i'm a
k-pop impersonator i see i'm more of a
k-pop performer than i am a listener
important distinction next question
kanye west came out in support of donald
trump and stirred up a cultural
firestorm but this wasn't the first time
that he did such a thing and stirred
criticism from his fellow elites back in
2009 kanye interrupted
which famous pop stars vma acceptance
speech i'm gonna be very disappointed if
you guys don't get this one
five
four
three
one
dave come on
damn you didn't
what'd you write
taylor swift whom he did not let finish
okay
knowles is right that is right i already
concede
i got the question a little screwy he
once did interrupt mike myers during
that hurricane thing remember that one
george bush doesn't care about black
people but then i realized what you said
and i wrote blonde girl i just couldn't
remember her name but she's blonde i
knew that part blonde girl does not
count we've gone to the panel of judges
and they have all agreed i'm the only
judge i'm the panel you remember you
remember that george bush does not care
about black people but you did not
remember that fiance had the greatest
album of all time of all time
yep michael coming on strong well done
all right all right next question what
is the full name of the race car driver
whose winning interview
sparked the infamous let's go brandon
meme so which race car driver was being
interviewed when let's go brandon was
born
dave you have the shirt on surely you
can get this right
you have the shirt i'm feeling pretty
good about my answer
michael what do you got brandon j
mcdrives a lot
i'm pretty i feel pretty good about that
dave
i also feel pretty good about mine i
couldn't quite remember his name but
let's go brandon
let's go brad that is cheap the
correct answer was brandon brown and i
for one am shocked that
i mean nascar's key audience is um yale
graduates and gay men in los angeles and
so
i personally would have thought you guys
were all over the nascar you know
there's a huge overlap between those two
with circles by the way the venn diagram
is almost just one circle but yeah very
close very close all right all right so
we're tied we're tied at the moment yes
tied i don't know if you guys want to
take too much pride in your performance
so far but we will continue there's
always room for improvement so far in
2021 how many of the top five
worldwide box office movies were
released in america so global box office
performance how many of them were
released in america out of the top five
what do we
got two
wow two
you guys both got it right well done
really it is two
the top five grossing movies of 2021 so
far according to our daily wireless
number one the battle at lake chang jin
of everyone
there that was uh china
hi mom that was china number three fast
and furious nine
number four no time to die and number
five detective chinatown
three the first and second are obvious
classics and the third one um wasn't as
good as the others but that was all
three of those released in china did you
guys know that i think number four is
going to be even better than the first
two
can i just say something i've been
wanting to get this off my chest for a
while so this seems like as good a time
as any i've never seen any of the fast
and furious i sense they're doing
something quickly they're angry about it
but i don't know what's going on over
there i've never seen any of them no i
saw one i think i saw one or two
and i i actually went down to cuba where
they filmed one of them but i have never
i don't i think there are superheroes
involved now i don't i don't know
anything i know one of the actresses
from it but i haven't seen them are you
able to disclose which one no
i'm afraid not we'll trust you oh i have
a girlfriend but she goes to another
school she lives in canada
she lives in canada
we've all heard that one before
next question for you fine gentlemen
this
these are not my words this is the word
of the question this obese hip-hop
artist is best known for her body
positivity and revealing outfits she has
presented herself as so sexually
titillating some commentators argue she
can even turn gay men straight curious
who is this famous obese hip-hop artist
known for her body positivity so there
there are two that i'm thinking of right
now
this one has bragged about dating
an nfl football player on the minnesota
vikings that's not helping i don't know
it's a line from one of her most popular
songs oh really so i don't know or
listen to that just the producer told me
in my ear
yeah i need a fat female rapper i mean
only one's coming to mind i got two in
one one though is like rapper slash
singer they say rapper she's a hip-hop
artist in general singer as well
she's and she's obese she's a singer and
a rapper boy she can do everything
five seconds uh all right whatever all
right
final answers what have we got
lizzo lil kim lizzo was the correct
answer
yes i didn't know the other option i had
in my head was have you ever heard of
the singer cupcake
is it's like lizzo is like a victorian
like opera singer compared to cup
cupcake is just pure porn but i i she
has like a music video on youtube and
she's like even more than but i'm glad i
got lizzo right that's good yeah didn't
lizzo didn't lizzo fight spiderman in
that remake wasn't that lizzo or am i
thinking of somebody else
i have no clue where is the chinese i
would love for the lizard maybe that was
the lizard yeah whatever yeah
all right all right he's up two to one
okay gentlemen can you name and this one
you only need to get one to get points
can you name literally any movie that
won an oscar this year
anyone
in in the year of our lord 2021 correct
um
and i have my computer ready because i
myself am not abundantly aware of many
of these uh
any movie that one no i know this isn't
right i know this isn't right uh
and uh sadly music videos do not qualify
so smokey smokey mike and the god king
was snubbed because of its status it
always is it always is
all right what do we got fellas
i said the all chick ghostbusters
was that last year i don't know i didn't
see it we're gonna go ahead and say no
on that one all right
that's oddly that's oddly close to what
i said which was shirley's secret now
that's just a movie i made up it's not
even a real movie but it sounds like
something that would have bought an
oscar shirley's secret it does meryl
streep stars a shirley she's got a
secret meryl streep as daniel day lewis
in shirley's secret early secret about a
gay 15 year old god yep okay um hold on
what's that i'm hearing that we might be
awarding a point to shirley's secret
never mind no points for either of you
i'm sorry
did ghostbusters get one that would have
been great um i was at the ready to type
in to look up and i started typing in
the all chick before i realized that you
were giving a completely ridiculous name
of a movie
moving on aaron rodgers recently got
into some hot water when he tested
positive for covet 19.
this result revealed that rogers never
received the fauci algae he misled the
press when he used what word to lead
everyone to believe that he had gotten
the vaccine
so when they asked if he'd been
vaccinated he used this word to
[Music]
maybe deceive them a little bit what was
that word and bonus point if you can
give
the position and team that aaron rodgers
plays for
five seconds
all right what do we got dave we'll
start with you
i believe the word maybe was yup
would it be yup by any chance it was not
i don't know okay
and and i believe he's the quarterback
for the packers right that's correct
we'll give you some points there you
earned those all right all right
is the word uh yes
no it is not is he the shortstop for the
brooklyn dodgers no
no he is not unfortunately okay the
quarterback of the
green bay packers the word he used was
immunized when they asked him if he had
been vaccinated he said i've been
immunized
i apologize that the phrasing on the
question was confusing so i'm going to
move on okay
so i got a point there we're tied you
did get a point oh all right
which teen pop star went to the white
house this year
to promote the covet 19
vaccine she from the video with anthony
falchi yeah yeah the two of them were
yucking it up
reading fan tweets oh man i do i
remember this happening
it's it's uh is it that girl who licked
the donuts oh god yeah
that doesn't narrow it down
who i i do actually remember this
happening
uh
girl get a video
biden did biden inappropriately touch
her am i getting i think he did yeah
okay he sniffed her all right i'm sort
of remembering it now
four
three
two one all right what do we got michael
to you
alicia jones
is that a real person michael no but i
knew like if i said miley cyrus i knew
that was wrong so i just i just guessed
a name
that is unfortunately incorrect all
right but if there are any alicia jones
out there watching yeah we see you and
we appreciate you dave
lizzy
lizzio
the correct answer gentlemen was
olivia rodrigo yes i remember that
actually yeah
no clue olivia rodrigo i think she might
be a tick talker also
aren't we all
who was the girl that uh licked the
donuts and then she said she hates
america who who am i thinking of that
was
that was michael's italian country woman
uh ariana grande ariana grande that's
who i was thinking of thank you thank
you
did she date pete davidson
see this is i feel hip
i know it's gross to think about but
yeah no i feel hip all right that's cool
all right
this nfl player became the first openly
gay man to play in an nfl game not an
nba game dave because that obviously
would have been you nba player
nfl first openly gay player in an nfl
game
uh and he was promptly cancelled because
it turned out that he was a registered
republican and had posted photos with
friends and trump shirts so he was
canceled for that but first openly gay
player in the nfl what was his name and
bonus points if you know what team he's
on
um
all right are either of you confident on
this one i'm i'm i'm pretty happy with
my answer i don't know if i would say
confident but i'm happy with it dave
we'll start with you then because i
don't want to give michael the pleasure
of getting to go first without
confidence yeah well i'm pretty sure my
answer could get me in legal trouble i
said joe montana
[Laughter]
we all knew it everyone was talking joe
montana and then although i do know that
joe montana only played for the 49ers
and later the chiefs i think maybe this
guy played for the tennessee titans
whatever his name might be no nothing no
not the titans unfortunately
we'll have to reach out to joe montana
no all right
i said brett
liberace farve
who played for the new york jets people
forget his nickname but
it was clear to those of us who were
paying attention
i was not paying close enough attention
to that okay for better or worse that is
uh incorrect the player was carl nassif
of the las vegas raiders
formerly the tampa bay buccaneers
okay you guys are no no points there no
although i'm tempted to give points for
the liberace reference thank you
next up this cultural figure claims to
have seen aliens
and recently said they would be
quote absolutely open to dating an alien
if given the chance did you did you just
use the singular they
i did and might that be part of the
question um
somebody said this i know it was like a
couple weeks ago
i actually think i know the answer
they would date aliens it was somebody
like
they also said that we should stop using
the term alien because it might offend
potential aliens
yeah it's a chick
it's sort of like dairy
chick i specifically said they it's a
them no but i think it's a i think it's
a chick she would date an alien
it's like a miley cyrus um
michael do you want to give him a hint
or do you want to no i want to get the
point
um forgive me
you got five seconds dave
three yeah this is two
one he's writing
michael because you seem pretty
confident we'll let dave go first
because i want to see uh the wrong
answer first okay
yeah well i don't think this is the
right answer but i'm pretty sure this
woman is an alien i said joy bait
they are they are
they is i'm so tempted to give half
points but again the panel says no
michael
demi lovato
all right that is correct thank you baby
they me as we now call her
they they meet lovato
i don't know what she has done like i
don't know why i know her name but i do
remember that she said she'd date an
alien dave not a big demi lovato fan
no no she's great and that thing she was
in uh you know like contact yeah is that
right yeah
[Laughter]
before we get on to the the next
question
michael i believe you have another
important word for us that you alluded
to earlier i do i have a word about the
word of god and that would be
uh exodus 90. i want you to think back
over the past 90 days how often did you
eat a little too much drink a little too
much spend a little too much time in the
office
how many times did you ignore your wife
children or friends just to thumb
through social media or watch netflix or
watch a game
so many men today are distracted they're
dependent on the comforts of this world
they're not in control of themselves
and
they can't say no to these kinds of
things they're not free to do that
we were made for more than this exodus
90 is a 90-day program that gets us back
to the fundamentals of the faith
prayer self-denial and fraternity more
than 50 000 men from around the world
catholics
protestants eastern orthodox even people
who don't align with christianity at all
have done this of these men 99 report
experiencing greater freedom this is
very important if we want to truly be
free it's not just about following our
base desires it's about disciplining
ourselves that's how we have true
freedom you can check it out for
yourself at exodus 90 dot com slash
michael that's exodus nine zero dot com
slash
michael i believe michael is up three
two producers is that correct
four three three oh you guys are scoring
more points than you even imagined so
dave got his bonus point
this one i'm confident that you two will
get
dave chappelle recently released a
netflix special that left the leftist
mob going after him once again for his
horribly insensitive jokes against the
transgender community what was the name
of this most recent dave chappelle
special
that got the people coming after him the
name of the dave chappelle stand up
special
i think it's one word i think maybe it
starts with a c
ah
michael what's that i said raw
is that
i think that was that
that was a different black guy
did i do a microphone
i believe that was bill cosby
what i did there pretty sure
i just wrote damn because i feel like i
should know it yeah skipped it a zillion
times and it's one word and i think it
starts with a c maybe it does start with
the c
closer the closer yeah really well i
didn't remember that at all i should get
something for that but i should get
something for that unfortunately not
this is not a hand grenade you should
get something for
that was that was pretty that was
pretty quick i tried not to laugh
uh next up this one i've been formed by
reliable sources that dave should be
good at
we'll see
name three songs from the village people
oh easy
this is another one i'll need help from
the producers on because
if it's not a certain
four-letter song i do not know any of
the other village people's songs
three is tough though do we get bonus
points for more than three
going to the panel and no only three
okay all right
um
do we get bonus points for singing them
i think our audience would say
definitely not please don't get it i'm
tempted to say yes how about you just
sing and then we'll just see where the
points go got it
seven seconds i did mine also in order
of greatness
village people's a great group i don't i
don't get the hate on the village people
are you a disco guy in general 100
percent
you know wait till you listen to that
frankie valley song
dave and i do you like disco we text
each other disco songs
all right what are the examples we've
got let's see them
i said ymca oh macho man
in the navy
and super ymca which i feel like is
probably a song actually
it's super ymca yes the the one in the
navy's by far the best one uh ymca
number three and number two macho man
yeah i want to be a macho man you know
i know you do
dave what does it make you feel when you
hear
michael singing in general especially
singing ymca and macho man and all those
classics
you know michael is a man who's very
comfortable with his sexuality
it's you know i i like to think that
because i am so profoundly
uh heterosexual you know i've just
brimming with that that you know i'm
restrained by the outer layer of uh
dancing to the village people
no no trust me i know he's heterosexual
last time he was at my house i tried to
give him tequila he said i only drink
whiskey and only a straight man
is is that a strip i
okay i didn't even know that was a thing
okay cabot
yeah
hope my wife doesn't watch it this
episode's going in whole new directions
we're going to go to the next question
before this gets any worse michael
though you get three points there dave
you get two okay
you know oh okay good ratio
yeah is that i don't know if that's how
it's supposed to work but that feels
like that was a good trade-off
which famous anti-trump intellectual
i don't know if that's a super
charitable name for this person but okay
which famous anti-trump intellectual
publicly admitted they were wrong about
the biden administration improving the
state of america
saying they are quote publicly eating
their words syllable by syllable
i mean there are like
there are like two
anti-trumpers left on the right
uh
dave seems confident
dave's confident
i'm gonna
i think some of them are so completely
far gone there's no hope of them ever
coming so i'm going to be i'm going to
go to the one that i think maybe there's
like a chance that he would he would
come around no no you're wrong am i
wrong
all right
let's let michael go first because
dave's team you go first you go first
okay i
i said it was david french i figured
bill crystal there's no way if that
whole crew there's no way but maybe
david because i like the pro-life stuff
maybe he would come around
what do you think
well he's wrong but his his inkling was
right but it was a sort of a trick
question because it makes it sound like
it's a hardcore conservative who said it
but in fact it is mild-mannered
neuroscientist and atheist
wow
wow
well done you were right
the michael's first inclination was to
assume it was someone on the right i did
i did
well done points for
mr rubin
hey have you talked to sam at all lately
not mistaken
no he unfollowed me on twitter
i'm a right-wing maniac i hang out with
you people i mean you know the liberals
the liberals are not nearly as tolerant
as they pretend to be no no that yeah
well he's going to be eating that too
someday that unfollow that uncharitable
sam harris
whatever i genuinely forgot that it
happened i don't know if i knew that
happened but i didn't mean to lead you
right into that
so we will move on all right
they don't believe in god but they
believe that trump is the devil
that's right
which musician wore a dress
and prompted candace owens to famously
preach that we need to bring back manly
men oh
which dress wearing musician
a musician
dress wearing musician prompted
candace's famous rant about manly men
just trended on twitter for
far longer than it probably should have
yeah yeah
now i remember this one of those was one
of those guys give me a second here one
of those guys uh musician
i'll give you a hint the village people
would not consider him a macho macho man
just as a hint
would would they not
actually he might qualify he's there i
don't know yeah
what do we got let's see him both at the
same time
harry styles frank sinatra
oh blue eyes was it not him
are you sure it wasn't
harry styles is the correct answer there
i mean he sang my way it's like
[Music]
yeah you're right you're right
there's so many just
things i want to say about that
impersonation of frank sinatra that was
just
i'm surprised as an italian
is not just horribly thick
no i'm just afraid i mean frank and his
enforcers are going to come knocking on
dave's door later that you don't get
away with insulting all blue eyes
next up
who was named people magazine's sexiest
man alive in 2021 i believe this just
came out like last week
people magazine sexiest man alive 2021
and
bonus points if you can give us his age
some people say that he doesn't age
hint
who is people magazine's sexiest man
alive
what do we got michael i see you it
looks like you're drawing what are you i
was about to drop but then you said what
do we got so i had to stop my drive i
had a good drawing coming out though you
can finish it dave let's let's see your
answer first while we allow michael to
finish his
the in drawing infallible fouchy and i
think he's 81 am i right i feel good
about this money i'm the sexiest man
alive
anthony falci
i'm going to leave the apology
impressions for noel now listen here you
you dirty remind it didn't turn out as
well as i thought but yes uh fauci i
said 80 though
i'm very surprised you both thought
falchy would be picked a sexiest man
alive this wasn't like time most
important person we're talking sexy
he what he is first of all he he's got a
certain charisma you know power is the
greatest aphrodisiac but second of all i
thought he i seem to remember that
headline yeah yeah i kind of remember
that headline too the correct answer was
actually paul rudd
no that's not true i'm looking this up
people magazine paul rudd it is true i
saw the cover photo and it's quite
ravishing oh you know what it was fauci
was rated most handsome murderer i think
that's what it was
most handsome uh demon incarnate demon
the guardian proclaims anthony fauci the
sexiest man alive cabot well we're
talking people magazine we don't believe
in the guardian over here in america all
right
yeah that's true fair enough that's true
final question
final question for you too let's hear
what's the score here uh producer
people
eight six this is perfect wow okay eight
down two i thought it was down one all
right two two-point question
here it is what is the name of the
company that actress gwyneth paltrow
created
that's right that features a candle
inspired by the smell
of her
reproductive body part
gwyneth paltrow
what is the name
of the company that has a candle
it smells like her
ladybug i've been to the store and i've
smelled her
and you gave us all that that image in
our minds now it is in fact goop
gentlemen well done you both get two
points but in the end
it wasn't enough for uh you to overtake
michael's lead
mr knowles the floor is yours to
celebrate however you choose thank you i
know that i technically won but i feel
like we all lost after that last answer
so i'm just
i'll i will be content
in my humble satisfaction dave thank you
for uh coming on the show and i look
forward to my wonderful ad read on your
very popular show
do i do that ad read right now or am i
actually doing it live on my show i will
gladly do it live you can do it right
now if you would like or you can do it
live we're going to give you the i want
it on his show i don't want it on here
people are already watching me on here
this is here's what i made a very good
point the producers i blame them they
said he can do it here if he likes i
think michael i think we should hold
dave to having to do this on his show
that was that's you know what i'm doing
knowles you won fair and square i'll do
a little read for you right now and then
i will talk about this this very thing
that we did right here yeah the white
board and the whole thing i'll talk
about it on my show and direct people to
this here video that would be great that
would be great i would love that can you
guys do a virtual can you guys do a
virtual handshake agreement first
thank you all right we now have 30
seconds on the clock mr rubin this will
go to you
you can really just use your heart your
soul whatever you feel necessary to say
listen i want to tell you guys about the
michael knowles show michael knowles is
such a thinker such a great conservative
pundit
that he wrote a book with no words which
became a bestseller then he wrote a book
with words that the new york times
completely ignored he likes to drink
scotch he has a lot of old dead
conservative friends that he talks about
all the time he loves frankie valli and
he's got good italian hair watch the
michael knowles show on the daily wire
goodbye
that's my new log line that's what's
going up right now at spotify baby that
was great dave thank you very much
i enjoyed this nols i don't care what
they say about you i i like working with
you
you know we we also did better than i
thought we would
everything being equal yeah you know you
know what you know what you won fair and
square i live in los angeles this
ridiculous gwyneth paltrow group stories
here i'm going to send you
please
please don't but i'll look out in the
mail i'll look out in the mail in case
it arrives
oh oh my guys are telling me we have one
in the bathroom here i'm going to just
send that one to you
[Music]
[Music]
you